it's
et's social study what the stars are
posting online young hip and carefree
Paris Jackson stuns in a sunny beach
snap that red stick your toes in the
sand
JLo has a family picnic with her twins
Max and Emmy after news broke that she's
dating Alex Rodriguez the singer rocked
a floral cutout dress to dine outdoors
with her kids they loved it they loved
it another mom of two soaking up the Sun
Jessica Simpson shows off her toned legs
in a pair of denim daisy dukes it's
amazing that we happen to do this
together moving on Orlando Bloom spends
quality time with he and ex Miranda
Kerr's son Flynn following his split
from Katy Perry
the proud dad shared a pic at an
amusement park while riding a roller
coaster
Orlando captioned the pic quote a
six-year-old will remind you of all the
important things in life
Emma West's soon running in the Bupa -
then there's makeup-free adele striking
a pose with Elmo in New York City after
he made a plea to sing with her and
check out Kelly Osbourne throwing it way
back to ten years ago with Adele she
posted a pic of the then 18 year old
singer co-hosting a British radio oven
with Osbourne
[Music]